you attended a state dinner you were
invited by the Obamas and Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau pretty cool yeah
as a Canadian to be honored that way how
was it it was kind of amazing cuz you
know you got to spend a little time with
the Obamas and I got to I got to spend
some time with with Prime Minister
Trudeau which is which was huge for me
because he's like our rockstar Prime
Minister amazing guy I swapped a quick
idea with him on how we can take Alaska
and he didn't go it's right there take
us forever to respond and we don't see
it coming no exactly exactly so but he
doesn't Canada's a little lower budget
he doesn't have Secret Service no one
would assure me away from it yeah yeah
you could just bug him all night no I
did oh yeah I was I was actually like
just my feet were sticking out of his
mouth by the end of the night and then
you shot a bottle rocket out totally
you